une chanson dans la tête aux éditions le
passeur alors vous avez une réputation
d' optimiste mais alors dans ce livre ça
va beaucoup plus loin parce que vous
qualifiez je commence par lens ans
puisque vous commencez par là évidemment
vous qualifier d' enfance heureuse
une enfance de moi je qualifierais d'un
peu tragique vous êtes victime de
violence vos parents sont extrêmement
violent l'un envers l'autre il ya des
tentatives de suicide que du côté de
votre mère comme de votre mère
conclusion de fabien lecoeuvre
j'ai eu une enfance heureuse oui eh ben
oui oui parce que je suis un optimiste
n'est on ne guérit pas de son enfance
mais en même temps moi toutes ces
épreuves
ces jeunes épreuves m'ont permis de me
construire est en fait mes parents ils
étaient tous que je ne voulais pas
devenir
c'est très important en terme de
philosophie c'est à dire que comme
disait saïd et là je le rejoins ce qui
est important ce n'est pas le but c'est
le chemin qu'on fait et on comprend
mieux les individus après vous avez
choisi une deuxième vie c'est la chanson
c'est à dire que vous aviez une vie
parallèle cinq ans par la chanson oui
c'est une compensation alors vous avez
fait une carrière ensuite attaché de
presse et de journalistes aussi vous
avez interviewé côtoyé ou travailler
pour tous les grands noms de la chanson